the law needs to look at journalism as a
thing you do not journalists does a
thing you are hi I'm Zach why smaller
for reason TV we're here with marc
randazza First Amendment attorney and
editor of the law culture and politics
blog the legal Satyricon mark thank you
very much for being here thanks for
having me recently you've been involved
in a case that's been grabbing a lot of
headlines the Steubenville Ohio case yes
there were a couple of high school
football players in this small town that
allegedly raped one of their classmates
who was possibly drunk and passed out at
a party yeah they took pictures of it
posted it on their social networks we're
making all sorts of nasty comments a
local blogger captured one of the photos
that had been put up on on Twitter and
put it on her blog and wrote some
commentary yes the gentleman who had
posted the picture on his Twitter
account then sued the blogger for
defamation correct and that's where you
come in what what attracted you to to
this case what this blogger was doing is
classic First Amendment protected
activity we can't live in a
self-governing society unless we have
information the local media stuffed this
story it was to the extent that they
wrote about it they were pretty bland
that's what I'm sorry why did the local
media stuff that story in your opinion I
mean that's I can make a little story
yeah I can only speculate but when you
have a town like Steubenville which you
know it although Dean Martin was born
there it doesn't really have much else
going for it except the football team
and from the reports I've read from what
locals there have told me this is you
know the big red football team there is
sacred and you don't want to upset the
applecart this blogger was disturbing
the apple cart as you put yes and so she
would not let the story go and kept
writing about the story until she got
sued for defamation I don't think there
was a shred of validity in the suit
because it was very quickly dropped yeah
what would have happened if this kind of
lawsuit had succeeded well I mean what
go with the broader implication we'll
think of the chilling effect yeah I
don't think we have a very good
independent media at least not in the
place where once was newspapers
magazines 24-hour news networks they do
a terrible job you know they take the
lowest common denominator of every story
they do it as quickly and as dumbly as
they can and we have now as bloggers
filling in the gaps are there cases
where people can legitimately say that
you're defaming me or is defamation
itself an infringement on free speech I
debate this with my First Amendment
lawyer brethren a bit and and some of us
believe that defamation itself is
incompatible with the First Amendment
that the only way that you cure bad
speech is with more speech I am not so
absolutist I do believe that there are
reputational harms that are properly
addressed in defamation suits I would
say though that you know for every call
that I get from somebody trying to bring
a defamation suit I usually talk ninety
percent of them out of it most of the
time when somebody brings a defamation
lawsuit it's what's characterized as a
slap suit could you explain what a slap
lawsuit is but yeah a strategic lawsuit
against public participation it's when
somebody brings a week defamation case
or traditionally defamation case
sometimes it'll be something else but
it's brought against somebody to stop
them from exercising their First
Amendment rights and generally they
don't care if they're going to win or
not because they win by punishing the
other party in states like Florida where
there is no anti-slapp statute you can
keep a plaintiff's defamation case going
for years before it finally gets thrown
out all the West Coast states have
enacted what's known as an anti-slapp
statute it stops that lawsuit
immediately while we figure out is this
a lawsuit brought against protected
speech if so does the plaintiff have a
reasonable likelihood of winning and if
the answer to that question is no that
case is over and they have to pay the
defendants attorneys fees I get the
sense that the internet and social media
have made First Amendment law just that
much more complex or interesting I mean
there's so many elements that have been
introduced people can speak anonymously
to so many different people what are the
gray areas that we that you see that
still kind of need to be navigated and
figured out one of the things that I
think needs some clarification is
whether there is a two-tiered system of
protection for the First Amendment as we
see traditional media not doing its job
that it's supposed to do that's why we
give them that extra privilege because
they're supposed to be the watchdog
they're supposed to be the Fourth Estate
well as they now become the public
relations wing of different political
parties or of the corporations that
actually own the media outlet are they
really providing that function or is
Miss Godard my client was she providing
that function the law needs to look at
journalism as a thing you do not
journalists as a thing you are you've
defended a number of pornographers
there's some who interpret the First
Amendment to say you know it protects
freedom of religion the press political
speech and that something like
pornography does not really fall within
that purview what do you say to that
kind of viewpoint [ __ ] it's
absolutely wrong that's the front line
of protecting free expression look
nobody's worried about protecting you
know Sesame Street no one's worried
about protecting nursery rhymes or
Christmas carols because that's all the
easy stuff and when it comes to
political speech that's the sacred core
but when you're out here if you can
protect you know anal bangers vol.5 well
then then it's not going to get any
closer to this cherished core and I want
to keep that border out as far as I can
when does it veer into being obscene do
you believe in the concept of obscenity
no not one of it I think there was no
such thing as a valid a constitutionally
valid obscenity law the last case I
wanted to talk about with you was you
defended the columnist amy alkon again
the TSA could you talk a little bit
about what happened there this alcon is
what like me somebody who thinks that
the body scanners are improper that the
war on terror has really done nothing to
make a safer but it is a war on the
fourth fifth and sixth amendments and so
she opts out as I do every time she goes
to the airport well TSA agents for the
most part are swine and they're kind of
the same low-level flunkies that have
run every I think every cultures shift
into totalitarian now are they going to
come after me for airing that you saying
this I hope so because you got a free
lawyer to defend X I think they know
that people who opt out have that kind
of contempt for them because
occasionally they do try to punish you
for opting out and the dalam McGee a TSA
agent here at LAX according to miss
alcon went a little bit overboard in her
pat-down jamming her fingers up into her
labia yeah and then she wrote about it
in her column and we got a demand from
Miss McGee's lawyer that Miss alcon
should have to pay her half a million
dollars for the emotional distress but
of course truth is a defense to any
claim of defamation it very much helped
that we have an anti-slapp statute in
California hmm you are definitely more
free in California Washington and Oregon
than you are in other states because of
its anti-slapp statute what is the
biggest threat in your mind to free
speech going forward from here and what
can we do what can the average citizen
do to push back against it be very
careful anytime you have somebody trying
to stifle someone else's free speech
when you hear speech that bothers you
you hear speech that repulses you speech
that disgust you I I think your first
instinct should be to protect that and
then fighting and then debate against it
but if your beliefs are so fragile that
they can't stand in opposition to
something that you find abhorrent
then maybe you need to look at your own
beliefs and modified thank you very much
for your time i'll click marc randazza
for reason TV I'm Zach why smaller